[Música]
buen día y bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 el invitado de hoy es el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
ucrania dmitro puleva que nos acompaña
desde quiero muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros
el placer es mío
señor ministro rusia anunció que había
atacado una fábrica de misiles cerca de
la capital este viernes
prometió más ataques significa esto que
la guerra vuelve a quien cree que es una
respuesta rusa al hundimiento de su
buque insignia en el mar negro
rusia lanzó esta guerra sin provocación
miremos lo que no necesita ninguna razón
legítima para atacar cualquier objetivo
en ucrania
entonces no debemos seguir esta lógica
de que rusia hace algo en respuesta a
las acciones de ucrania
rusia actúa así porque está en una
guerra agresiva y trata de derrotarlos
es cierto que algunas ciudades de
ucrania incluida kiev han sido
alcanzadas por ataques de misiles
recientemente pero esta es la vida que
hemos aprendido a vivir en los últimos
meses
quiero volver al hundimiento del moskvá
el buque insignia de la flota rusa del
mar negro que se hundió el jueves los
rusos dijeron que fue un incendio y
luego que fue debido al mal tiempo
usted dijo que se trata de un ataque
ucraniano
está seguro de que esto es exactamente
lo que ocurrió
permítame decirle esto
ucrania no tiene miedo
ucrania no tiene miedo de defenderse y
de atacar objetivos que supongan una
amenaza para nuestro país y nuestro
pueblo
entendemos que esta es la guerra y
tenemos que defendernos
es doloroso para rusia admitir lo que
ocurrió con este buque insignia pero la
historia revelará la verdad y estoy
ansioso por escucharlo
pero la verdad para usted que fue un
ataque de misiles ucraniano contra ese
buque insignia
la verdad para mí es que el buque
insignia que disparaba misiles contra
las ciudades ucranianas
y mataba a los civiles ucranianos
que están las profundidades del mar
negro
esa es la verdad
[Música]
usted mencionó los ataques en kiev y
otras ciudades pero todas las miradas
están puestas en el este del país
le preocupa que pueda ser peor que nunca
ante vladimir putin no pueda permitirse
volver a quedar mal que esté preparado
para lo peor
todos deberíamos dejar de preocuparnos
por la reputación del presidente putin
tomó la decisión de atacar a un país
soberano
que no suponía ninguna amenaza para él
su ejército cometió atrocidades infames
en ucrania asesinatos torturas
violaciones no creo que nadie en europa
o en todo el mundo deba basar su
política hacia putin en el principio de
que necesita salvar su reputación hay
que derrotarlo por todos los medios
militar política y económicamente este
debería ser el objetivo que debería unir
a todos los países que defienden la
democracia y el estado de derecho
quiero hablar de la situación en la
ciudad suroriental de mariupol
la situación es extremadamente
preocupante así
hay informes de que los rusos o las
tropas pro rusas están enterrando
cuerpos
y llevan un crematorio móvil
presumiblemente para borrar cualquier
evidencia de lo que hemos visto en busca
de anca
esta es también la información que usted
tiene
lamento confirmar que
tras los asesinatos de atrocidades y
muchas otras ciudades cercanas ayer
los rusos que entendieron que tenían que
centrarse en cubrir las huellas de sus
crímenes en otras partes de ucrania
estoy en contacto con alguien que sigue
mario ball
recibe información de primera mano desde
allá y puedo confirmar que la magnitud
de los crímenes cometidos por rusia en
bario polvo es aún mayor de lo que hemos
visto muchas y otras partes de la región
de guerrilla
usted es el diplomático en jefe siguen
las conversaciones con rusia van a
llegar a alguna parte
dado lo que estamos presenciando sobre
el terreno igual que parece que va a
ocurrir en un futuro próximo en el este
del país
seré franco con usted
cada día de combates cada nueva casa que
rusia destruye
cada nueva víctima civil
complica las conversaciones
hace más y más difícil las negociaciones
y en los últimos días los expertos
ucranianos y rusos tuvieron conferencias
virtuales para discutir si hay alimentos
de imposible acuerdo entre los dos
países pero no lograron ningún progreso
todos entendemos que es el presidente
putin quien tiene que tomar las
decisiones
y vemos como rusia está desarrollando la
batalla en el donbass diremos que ahora
se centra en soluciones militares no
diplomáticas
así que si no avanzan y siguen
estancadas estaría dispuesto a decir en
un momento dado dejemos de hablar y
sigamos luchando
no creo que esta sea la forma de actuar
con diplomacia al final
todas las guerras terminan con un
acuerdo
así que tenemos que seguir hablando pero
entendemos que el futuro de esta guerra
se decide en el campo de batalla no en
la mesa de negociaciones
hablando del campo de batalla
eeuu anunció una ayuda militar adicional
de 800 millones de dólares para ucrania
incluyendo helicópteros tanque es 40
minutos en tire de artillería
y también se habla de que los ucranianos
obtendrán drones muy sofisticados como
el repair
está viendo llegar a ucrania armas cada
vez más sofisticadas porque lo viene
exigiendo una y otra vez
si estamos viendo el aumento de armas en
ucrania y esa es la única manera como
nuestros socios deben actuar porque la
guerra continúa y
defendemos heróicamente nuestro país
sacrificamos nuestras vidas y lo mejor
que pueden hacer los socios es
proporcionarnos todas las armas
necesarias
de hecho este es el trato justo que
ucrania le propone al mundo
ustedes nos dan todo lo que necesitamos
para luchar y nosotros hacemos el resto
del trabajo luchamos en nuestro
territorio para que ustedes no se
involucren en esta guerra
creo que es un trato justo
y animo a todos los países incluida
francia a que sigan el caso de eeuu y
aumenten sus entregas de armas tras
esos drones que mencioné van a ser
entregados a ucrania
y lo comprobaré con nuestro ministerio
de defensa y el último paquete de apoyo
para mí el elemento más importante e
irracionalidades de artillería con los
estándares de la otan
que son muy necesarias en el esta
intranet
no me centraré en otros elementos
pero vemos que eeuu están enviando más
armas y más avanzadas
esto que es importante
y no hay otra alternativa
los otros miembros de la otan deben
hacer lo mismo y empezar a enviarle a
ucrania
armas con los estándares de la otan
hablando de otro miembro de la otan que
hay de alemania
bueno alemania pasó por una revolución
en los primeros días de la guerra cuando
le dio un giro de 180 grados a su
política de suministros de armas
antes del 24 de febrero
alemania había insistido en que nunca
enviarían armas a ucrania
que eso era parte de su política
tras el anuncio de la guerra nos
enviaron algunas armas y agradecemos
este paso pero pueden hacer mucho más
y esperamos que el gobierno alemán ante
una decisión que permita el suministro
de armas pesadas a ucrania
no sólo estamos defendiendo a ucrania
sino los amigos de este instante estamos
defendiendo europa
y alemania debe entender que lo mejor
que puede hacer es apoyar a ucrania por
todos los medios
qué pasa con francia ayer tuvo una
conversación con su homólogo francés
francia anunció que volvería a trasladar
su embajada aquí en el futuro próximo
está usted satisfecho con este gesto y
también con la ayuda de francia ucrania
si mantengo un contacto regular con mi
homólogo ochoa y filiar el crecimiento
si lynch que habla regularmente con el
presidente macro
así que la calidad de nuestro diálogo
con francia es apreciada y bienvenida
espero poder ver el regreso del
embajador carcesa pierre tengo entendido
que la embajada reanudará su trabajo a
partir del lunes esto es muy bienvenido
y animamos a todos los países a que
vuelvan a kiev y empiecen a trabajar
aquí
estamos trabajando contra ancianos
suministros de armas este es uno de los
temas que estamos discutiendo con ellos
queremos ver más decisiones de francia
en ese sentido pero el papel de france
también es muy importante europea a la
hora de imponer nuevas sanciones contra
rusia
francia ayuda a movilizar el apoyo a los
anteriores paquetes de sanciones
el próximo paquete el sexto está en
camino
y discutió en particular con el ministro
francés la necesidad de introducir el
embargo del petróleo
para que la unión europea no compre
petróleo ruso
y deje de subvencionar la maquinaria
bélica rusa
y siente que los franceses están a favor
de ese embargo al petróleo ruso
tengo la impresión de que francia está
abierta a discutirlo y eso es bueno
no creo que hayan tomado la decisión
final
pero probablemente tengamos que esperar
hasta la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones francesas para seguir
hablando
pero eso es bueno ver que francia está
abierta a la idea porque francia según
tengo entendido
busca la manera de compensar el petróleo
ruso con suministros de otros países
hablando de francia hace poco una
disputa sobre el tema del genocidio
obviamente ucrania considera que rusia
está llevando a cabo un genocidio
en
el mismo piensa justin pudo el
presidente francés no está de acuerdo su
presidente dijo que esas palabras le
hirieron profundamente
entonces piensa que emanuel macrón está
haciendo esto para mantener sus canales
con vladimir putin abiertos si es así
cree que es una buena manera de hablar
de este tema
gateway su cabal decisión
antes del 24 de febrero cuando empezó la
guerra
siempre escuchábamos de parís pero
también de otras capitales europeas como
berlín
tenemos que hablar con putin tenemos que
mantener las puertas abiertas no tenemos
que presionarles demasiado porque no
tenemos que provocar lo tenemos que
evitar una escalada
y toda esa política fracasó fracasó
porque no sirvió para detener a footing
putin siguió atacando a ucrania
por lo tanto le pedimos a berlín a parís
ya otras capitales que reconsideren está
política
y que acepten el hecho de que es hora de
unirse es hora de adoptar una postura
firme contra putin y su país
no es el mejor momento para buscar
maneras de complacerlo de encontrar un
punto común con él porque no responde a
eso
el presidente macro le hizo un enorme
esfuerzo para evitar que putin iniciara
una guerra pero aquí estamos la guerra
está ahí así que es hora de cambiar el
enfoque francesas en rusia en conclusión
tiene que francia y su presidente
calificarán de genocidio lo que está
ocurriendo en ucrania
si ahora es el momento de hacerlo
lamento profundamente decirlo porque le
está ocurriendo a mi pueblo llama país
pero cuanto más dure esta guerra más
evidencia de odios
específicamente hacia los ucranianos
como nación
como grupo se revelarán y por lo tanto
al final creo que estas atrocidades
cometidas por los rusos serán
calificadas como genocidio legalmente
dmitro culeba muchas gracias por ser
nuestro invitado en la entrevista de
france 24 desde kiev y gracias a ustedes
por haberla visto
what's
[Música]